um prime minister the southeast the
South West Midlands the north you're
losing everywhere prime minister why is
that it's always disappointing to this
hard-working conservative councilors
their friends their colleagues and I'm
so grateful to them for everything that
they've done in terms of the results
it's still early we've just had a
quarter of the results in but what I am
going to carry on doing is delivering on
the people's priorities halving
inflation growing the economy reducing
debt cutting waiting lists and stopping
the boats that's what people want us to
do that's what I'm going to keep hard at
doing now the ex-conservative leader of
Medway Council blamed the unpopularity
of your government cost of living plans
the planning changes NHS failings that's
all down to you a clear message from
voters what's gonna change look as I
said we've only had a quarter of the
results in actually we're making
progress in key election Battlegrounds
like Peterborough Bassett Law Sandwell
but the message I am hearing from people
tonight is that they want us to focus on
their priorities and they want us to
deliver for them and that's about
halving inflation growing economy
reducing debt cutting waiting lists and
stopping the boats that's what people
care about that's what they want us to
deliver and that's what I and the
government are going to work very hard
to do
what early Trends is that working-class
voters look like they're going back to
the labor party do you take personal
responsibility for the overall vote and
did Boris Johnson have something that
you don't well if you look at the
results we've only had a quarter of the
results in so it's hard to draw firm
conclusions we're actually making
progress in key electron Battlegrounds
like Peterborough light Sandwell like
Basset law for example and you mentioned
the labor party look I'm not detecting
any massive Groundswell of movement
towards a labor party or excitement for
their agenda what people want us to do
is focus on their priorities halving
inflation growing the economy reducing
debt cutting waiting lists and stopping
the boats those are the country's
priorities those are this government's
priorities and that's what we're going
to deliver
what does the coronation tomorrow mean
for you and do you think everybody
should take the oath I think everyone
will be sending our best wishes to their
majesties the king and queen ahead of
the coronation and it's a moment of
enormous national pride it's a
demonstration of our country's character
and it's an opportunity for us to all
look to the Future in a spirit of
service hope and unity